okay so I think we'll go ahead and try
to get started here today so today we
have a presentation by one of our NLM
PhD students
Dana Womack and Dana comes to us from a
rather unique background and that she
has acute clinical nursing background as
well as high-tech background at Intel
she's worked on projects related to ONC
and she's going to be sharing with us
her initial ideas about her dissertation
on ambient data a new source of insight
so I'll turn it over to Dana thank you
thank you dr. Eaton and thank you
everyone for being here today it just
means a lot that you're here to
participate in my symposium so my goals
for today are to share my research
interests to identify gaps that I'd like
to address in my dissertation research
and to enlist your ideas and suggestions
because the next thing is a dissertation
proposal which is very much a work in
progress and your feedback will only
make it stronger by way of topics I'd
like to introduce the opportunity space
but I'm going after a bit about my
personal motivation we'll go to a review
of literature on some work force and
patient safety related topics and then
we'll delve a bit deeper into the
research gap that I want to address and
look at some exploratory work that was
done over the summer and end with next
steps so the opportunity space that I'm
really excited about is this
intersection of patient safety the work
experience of clinicians and extracting
value from all available data I feel
like these three circles are highly
complementary and at the center there's
some space for some really interesting
interdisciplinary research and that we
can bring informatics to the table to
really move the bar on both patient
safety and clinicians work experience at
the same time so why do I care about
this topic I'll start with an anecdotal
story I started out my career as an
orthopaedic and neurosurgery nurse at a
community hospital in rural Indiana I
come to work one day one of my patients
is going to a nursing home she had
fallen broken her hip and knee
a little more rehab and so shortly after
changing strict report the ambulance
showed showed up to take her transfer
her to the facility and I realized need
to quickly go to the chart make sure
everything was in order and as I was
looking at the turn I realized oh no she
had not yet had her PVD placed nor her
chest x-ray which is a mandatory thing
to screen for tuberculosis before a
nursing home would ever accept her so I
had to run down the hall till the
ambulance guys sorry gotta take her off
the gurney explained to the patient what
was going on
fire off stat orders to pharmacy and
radiology meanwhile my patient other
patients are having to wait who knows
what the impact was to patients on other
units whose radiology was attending to
my need rather than theirs and I just
felt like I was putting out putting
setting fires all around me and it was
completely wasted in unnecessary energy
and the story played itself out day
after day variations on the story
sometimes the outcomes were relatively
small like a delayed discharge sometimes
they were larger sometimes it was like
oh my god I'm so glad we caught this or
that could have been really bad so I
wanted to talk to my nurse manager about
it and I said you know every day I feel
like there's these things that happened
that are largely out of my control I
went into nursing to provide excellent
care and I feel like there's compromises
and I can't always do anything about
them and this is really frustrating to
me as a nurse and I'll never forget what
she said because it was a pivotal
comment that has really shaped the
direction of my career and she said Dana
we just need more conscientious nurses
like you and it was really one of the
most disheartening compliments I've ever
received because here's what I heard is
it's going to be the same tomorrow I'm
not enlisting you in helping to solve
this problem and I don't see this as a
system issue because a solution to space
and effective care is to have
conscientious clinicians now I have no
argument you need content as clinicians
what I really my perspective is that you
need conscientious clinicians working in
a system that's designed to help them
deliver safe care so from that moment
forward I started plotting my exit from
this rural Hospital in Indiana because I
knew it had to be bigger better in the
big city I just needed to get there so a
friend of mine and I signed up as
traveling nurses and we started Criss
crossing the nation and we would take 8
to 13 weeks I
in large and small hospitals and what we
found is that unfortunately this is a
universal challenge that clinicians and
patients face in hospitals all over the
US and in fact some of the places where
we worked because there's also reasons
why people our Hospital will go to the
extra expense of bringing in contract
labor is that their environments that
were actually much worse and more
dangerous than our original Hospital in
Indiana so then I started plotting a
change in my role because working as a
nurse in the status quo organization was
just unacceptable to me I'd heard about
informatics and so in 2000 I finished a
master's degree in nursing informatics
at the University of Utah and switched
into industry because I was really
fascinated with this idea of listening
and user needs and translating them into
functional requirements for new software
solutions so return product development
and in software implementation again
crisscrossing the nation the red dots
here represent places where I've worked
clinically and the green dots are places
where I implemented software and loved
mice in an industry of fabulous and I
learned a lot but I never felt like I
was really directly addressing the
issues that prompted me to go into
informatics in the first place so here I
am in 2016 extending my skill set and
doubling down on those original
motivations so let's talk for a minute
about the hospital environment it's a
fascinating place you have really
dedicated staff working with really sick
patients in a in a fast-paced dynamic
environment and you've got it really
interesting each patient is kind of an
interesting collection of building
blocks
you've got evidence-based guidelines you
have that tell you you know hire you and
workup a patient how you're going to
treat a patient clinical pathways what
you should expect on post-op day one
plus that day to hundreds of policies
and procedures and each of these has an
evidence base or most of them are
evidence-based and each patient has a
different collection of these building
blocks and so in what habits we spend a
lot of effort making sure that all of
the building blocks have a good evidence
base so we have much less than evidence
about knowing what happens when you
select different building blocks are
applicable to this patient and then you
have this collection of patients that
are all taken care of by a subset of
clinicians at the point of care so I
think Grand Kerfoot put it very
beautifully when they said there's a
need to grow an evidence base for
effective Hospital leadership practices
and care delivery practices in critical
clinical care environments that are
often characterized by chaos turbulence
and complexity and nothing would make me
happier than if my research could help
contribute to that growing evidence base
so let's take a short look at what we
know in the literature first looking at
workforce issues there are physical
shortages in nursing and in other
professions and in 2009 there is a
survey done of nurses and nurses
overwhelmingly said that the single
thing that you could do to help relieve
the nursing shortage was to improve the
work environment which really suggests
that nurses are making choices about
where they work based on the clinical
casques characteristics of the care
environment and it's not just nurses if
we jump forward to 2016 physician
burnout it's becoming a really important
topic to look at last year those the
physician foundation survey found that
nearly half of physicians experience
feelings of burnout on a frequent or
continual basis and nearly half of the
physicians surveyed said that they plan
to either retire cut back on their hours
or seek non clinical roles so just think
about what that's going to do for the
work environment of the questions that
stay there and what that might do for
access to care multitasking is another
aspect that I'm highlighting because it
affects both patient safety and the work
experience of clinicians and through
observational studies we know that
Hospital has spend about 16 percent of
their time multitasking for nurses it's
a little more about a third of their
time and they're interrupted as
frequently as every six minutes which
leads to a challenging work environment
from both the work experience annotation
safety perspective
patient safety has been an important
focus for at least 150 years probably
more than that but the first study that
I'm citing here is dr. Semmelweis who is
a very observant physician and he
noticed that when physicians examine
cadavers didn't wash their hands and
then delivered babies that often these
illimitably get sick was what they
called tell bed fever at the time
because the germ theory wasn't even
really yet known in 1860 and the you
know this was kind of a radical idea at
the time but it was one of the early
recognitions that you know seeking
health care can actually result in harm
to the patient in the 1670s
there were studies on length of stay
errors of writing and prescriptions in
the early 90s there was a very large
Harvard Medical Practice study where
they looked at thousands of
hospitalizations and found that a lot of
them contained adverse events many of
them were preventable or related to
negligence and this study was then
replicated and together those two
studies formed the basis for the numbers
that were used in that landmark 1999 IOM
report to err is human were they
estimated at 44 to 98,000 deaths occur
unnecessarily related to patient harm
this report launched a whole bunch of
efforts in patient safety a report a
couple years later from the IOM look at
the quality chasm report list systems
and the role of systems and supporting
safe and effective care and many
interventions ensued the ones that I'm
highlighting both because it was
effective and also because it
illustrates the point that interventions
could through the validation if you
don't need to be elaborate very simple
things like checklist for making sure
that you're following correct procedure
when you change a dressing on a central
line can dramatically reduce the
infections that patients experience and
then in 2015 the Institute for
Healthcare Improvement looked back and
they were like well where have we common
like what happened in the time ensuing
from the IOM report and their overall
conclusion is that yes we've made
progress especially in the area of
hospital-acquired
actions but there's a lot of work left
to be done and we need like the
sustained and holistic focus on patient
safety it's not the new and Pech C topic
anymore but it's nonetheless needed keep
bringing it closer to home let's look at
some examples of what informatics has
done to help patient safety
we definitely clinical decision support
has been a big focus and informatics in
antibiotic prescribing drug drug
interactions drug allergy many other
clinical topics human factors has been
embraced those by informatics and by the
medical community as a whole is like
they with a user interfaces the way our
work is constructed it definitely has an
impact and we need to look at these
things in parallel with things like more
evidence-based paradigms or
evidence-based medicine paradigms
structured data is a staple in
informatics and an example there is
there has been a classification system
developed so that we can study all of
the errors that were related to use of
the electronic health record or other
clinical electronic devices and then
here at OHSU our own doctor ash and
others created the safer guides which
are self assessments that organizations
can execute to optimize the safety and
use of their EHRs
so take a quick look a deeper look at
the Institute for Healthcare Improvement
safety recs from 2015 where they said
you know what where have we come in 15
years and now where should we go from
here and on the Left we have a lot of
very good but more general
recommendations and on the right I've
highlighted three recommendations that
really relate to the opportunity space
I've identified and informatics the
first is to create a common set of
safety metrics that reflects meaningful
outcomes and proactively identify risks
and hazards second is to support the
workforce so that clinicians can achieve
their full potential as healers and the
third is to ensure that technology is
safe and optimized to support space
patient care a leader in safety in many
different industries including
healthcare is James reason and he's
identified that
safety in subversive ents really have
two primary sources the first is active
failures which are like you know humans
actually flips and lapses and things
like that and the other is latent
conditions these are more error-prone
conditions in the workplace and I love
his quote we can't change the human
condition suggesting that you're not
going to be able to ever eradicate all
active failures but we can can change
the conditions in which human work so
suggesting that focusing on blatant
errors is really where you want to go if
you want to get more practice in
managing safety so where are we right
now and what do we do in terms of
measuring patient safety if you look out
at the ark patient safety metrics most
of them start out with the word rate
rate of X rate of retained surgical
items rate of infections related to a
central line catheter a rate of pressure
ulcers and so you've already had an
event that's occurred and you're
measuring how frequently does that occur
and then you're benchmarking yourself
against other organizations which is an
important thing to do another focus that
we've that we have along this lines is
once an event has occurred to conduct a
root cause analysis to really understand
how and why and contributing factors to
that event
but if you want to in the spirit of the
IHI recommendations move upstream to a
more proactive focus on patient safety
you're going to have to start looking at
latent conditions which begs the
question how do you identify what latent
conditions in the healthcare environment
contribute to adverse events so this is
just that you need the ability to
estimate risk in real time but to do
that you're going to need to know a
little bit about what are these error
provoking conditions and to identify
those you're going to need more granular
and detailed information about what's
going on in your healthcare environment
so the research gap that I'd like to
address is really the development of
methods to identify what are the latent
error producing characteristics that
exist in patient care environments how
can we recognize them how can we
identify what they are and is it
possible to start looking at these in
real-time so that we can take proactive
interventions when these conditions are
known to be present and so that we can
prevent adverse event so this leads me
to the idea of ambient data and Mayor
data is really data that's produced as a
byproduct of care by devices that were
meant primarily for was to support
logistical functions so you have
medication systems the primary purpose
there is getting meds to the nurse to
get them to the patient communication
devices supporting communication between
staff and other departments the nurse
call button is you know how patients
identify that they need somebody to come
into their room to help them and so the
primary purpose is really to facilitate
the logistical aspects of care execution
but behind all of these systems you have
like log files that have little records
of all of these events that occur and
currently these are siloed and they're
not they're not typically analyzed even
in a system by system way but definitely
not in aggregate so to just kind of give
you a visual of how ambient data works
you can think of you know this is a
typical patient hallway and you have
these little digital footprints of
activity that are taking place behind
every door in every med room and in the
hallways and you from a superficial
level if you were just looking at a snap
point snapshot in time you can see you
know what activity is taking place but
you can also start to infer a deeper
meaning from this for example if you
dispense d50 or dextrose 50% on a
med-surg unit really the only reason you
do that is when a diabetic crash and you
need to elevate their blood sugar really
quickly and so you know that a nurse is
going to be busy recovering a patient a
physician is going to be paged you might
need a bed in the ICU and you can start
thinking about how you can develop
deeper knowledge
from the knowledge of activities that
are taking place at the bedside so I
really want to help health care
organizations get value out of their
ambient data but I knew that it was too
much of a leap to go from you know just
this idea to you know writing a
dissertation proposal because Lam's if
people aren't willing to give you access
to their data or what happens if it's in
such a format that you really can't
analyze it so over this past summer
through the help of many people some of
you are here in the audience today I was
able to gain at IRB approval and access
to ambient data from the hospital for a
post surgical unit here at OHSU I had
data from five electronic systems that
were operational systems and two that
were more focused on outcomes of safety
events and overtime and this resulted in
over 40,000 date/time stamp events if
you do the math for a month that's about
one per minute and the ambient data I
pulled is a fraction of ambient data
that exists so it kind of gives you an
idea of the level of transparency of
activity that might be able to be
achieved through looking at ambient data
so what did we learn it seems that
ambient data this is the top graph is
basically just a look at the volume of
activity over time and you can see that
it these are the hours of the day and
it's a month worth of data so you can
see the activity ramps up at 7:00
stays fairly consistent during the day
and then starts to drop off in late
evening in the wee hours of the morning
here on the second graph this was
looking at medications and you can see a
strong temporal pattern where there's a
lot of medications that are given that
hour you know twice a day be ID'd med
times but that medications are also
delivered at all hours of the day this
view is we have our nurses on the left
and then they're you know each nurse is
caring for multiple patients and we have
just basically counts this is activity
count across the bottom of the activity
that they're conducting through the day
based on what we had access to you can
there wasn't a lot of variability and
how many times they went in and out of
the med room the blue dots but there is
variability and like how many meds they
actually dispensed to their group of
patients how many times they
communicated with each other which is a
green squares and how many times their
patients summoned them to the bedside
which are the orange squares and when I
started showing this to the nurse
manager and clinicians on the unit they
were like wow this would be really great
because it could help us start to
identify if there's equitability and you
know parity in our patient loads and
help us understand really what's going
on for the unit but in order to help
really do patient assignments you kind
of need to set a patient level as well
so we made this visualization where we
have our nurses our superheroes and
using two names at the top and then our
patients in columns and you could
certainly you know add numbers to
represent different aspects this is
really looking at volume of activity and
so from a patient assignment perspective
you just want to make sure that you're
not having all the big dots under the
same nurse column so here it's the
standard suggest that you know we have
iron men taking care of Corky taking a
lot of PRN meds and Wonder Woman has a
patient who's using the call light a lot
fat girls kind of evened out and
Supergirl has some people taking you
know scheduled in Speier and us and so
again these are just three sources of
data that I had they haven't been
combined in any sort of more
sophisticated way they could be we we
talked with the nurses about would it be
great if we could create a summary
measure that kind of was like a you know
weighted in some way so that you're not
having multiple bubbles but obviously we
need to first understand you know what's
driving activity with driving workloads
here's another view looking at
medications and in this view we have our
RNs on the Left we have our patients
across the top the size of the square
represents the volume of med soda
patients receiving in the color the
depth and color represents how many of
those are pure in meds pyramids are
really interesting because they
represent that you're actively managing
something with a patient they're in pain
very have nausea they are having
difficulty breathing so something's
happening physiologically with them
that's also being reflected in activity
that's taking place on the unit and so
we you know kind of brainstormed ways
that this might give you insight into
both patient assignment as well as how
patients are doing but an idea that came
with what could we use this to kind of
show patient trajectories and how are
they doing over time and how might we
use ambient data to do that so this
visualization looks at we have the days
of the month across the top our patients
across to the left and this is
summarizing their medication intake
during their hospitalization and what
you notice here is that you know
patients tend to have they start out
with like more medications and then it
decreases which kind of makes sense on a
post-surgical for your you know
decreasing your PRN meds before they're
ready for self-care and home we have one
patient here it's quieted here quite a
long time variable use of meds and then
this patient here is kind of interesting
because it was like started like ramping
up towards the end now I didn't have
diagnosis or disposition data so I don't
know what actually happened to that
patient but it makes you to start
thinking about ways you might be able to
use this data was was was she bounced
back to the idea was she did she go home
like that and was she at high risk for
readmission you know you could start
thinking about ways that you might look
at patient trajectories and patterns of
patient directories in relationship to
an outcome that you really care about
and then the last example of how we
might be able to use this data is to
overlay activities of interest so here
we have a staff nurse call systems July
4 was issued in the mid afternoon and
here this is the beginning a night shift
very unusual to have three RNs have 45
minutes of overtime on the same shift
something obviously went down and I'm
not suggesting that we can learn
anything but just by looking at the
activity patterns which are in the
background here because this is just you
know a very small end but if we started
looking at the identifying patterns of
activity and then looking at we know
when are those over times one of those
matters we might be able to really start
identifying that activity that relates
to an outcome of interest there are
quite a few challenges in working with
ambient data first of all the data
doesn't hang together very well some of
the systems this data wasn't designed
for analysis virtualization it's
basically just a record and and whoever
designed the systems just design log
files to do it if you had a need you to
go back and see what happened and so
there are systems that know just about
the fast person and other systems know
just about the patient or maybe they
know just about the room number but not
the patient name and so you have to
start and even when you know about the
staff in two different data sources for
example the way staff are identified in
visera the communication device is a
different identifier then is used in on
the cell which is the medication
dispensing device and so you know for
good reasons it had to do with a
technical limitation of an interface
device but now so if you had a need for
your visera to be interfaced with a
nurse call they used your cafeteria ID
in visera otherwise they use your
employee ID and so now of a sudden you
need a crosswalk between the burrito
codes and the ID codes in order to get
all this data to hang together so those
are definitely you know things that need
to be worked through and ironed out and
this might be interesting in that you'd
be surprised at how difficult it is to
identify which nurse took care of which
patients this is truly and I've
recreated it using the pseudonyms but
this is exactly what they're using for
an ER space
assignment on the study in it that I
pulled data from over the summer where
you have a list of your staff names and
the shift and then you hand right in the
bed number and the patient name and
these are scanned into PDF files and
those becomes the official record of who
had whom so we're like okay we have a
great electronic record system here like
there's gotta be a way and we found out
you know what there's three ways in our
EHR that you can identify yourself as
taking care of a patient but none of
them are used consistently and so you
know it leads you to questions of if you
really want to analyze this ambient data
what I did is I like manually hung it
all together by looking at the names and
I created a clean data set to create the
visualizations as an example but we're
going to have to overcome this if we
want to create it into a live system and
one way is you could look at other
systems where you're assigned in the
visera call system so that you get calls
from the right bed numbers or you might
infer it based on the nurse who's most
frequently giving meds to a patient are
some ideas that have come up but what
our next steps so everybody needs a big
hairy audacious goal and mine would be
this but we start aggregating data
ambient data from multiple hospitals and
create basically a learning system that
helps identify what are the latest 8d
conditions that we need to start
monitoring and this could happen you
know we could even grow this further so
that it would be hospitals in multiple
countries and that this would contribute
to an evidence base of effective care
delivery but on a more practical level
like what are the steps I mean like how
could we start taking steps toward that
vision and one more thing though is that
back to that vision I think it could be
really interesting because this data in
a way is a lot less sensitive like we
have visions of having a learning health
system where we're sharing electronic
health record in a very you know
nationwide or international way but you
know cheering data about how many times
the call light was pushed or how many
meds were dispensed or the percentage of
meds that were pyramid is a lot less
sensitive than sharing somebody's
clinical data so it could be possible
that this could even serve as if you
were successful
kind of a template or help people gain a
vision for what could be done with even
richer data source okay so back to our
key steps the first thing is to really
develop the capability to listen to this
data you've got to be able to hear when
it's happening aggregate it in real-time
and then after that you have to
normalize it even the way dates and
times are represented in this data is
not the same maybe you have the date in
one column the time in another column or
you have a single date timestamp and in
one it's measured at the second level in
another at the subsection level and so
you've got some normalization of
identifier terms scaled that needs to
occur then we can get to the part where
where it gets a little more interesting
we can start analyzing this data what
are features what are patterns in this
data and how do they relate to things of
interest like clinical directories or
workloads or medication errors or
overtime or any of these outcomes of
interest and then ultimately this is
where we have more and more value we
have increasing data manipulation and
more value to the users when we can
actually give them actionable
informations like right now you're at
risk for X and here's what you can do to
reduce your risk of that so where are we
right now in order to do the research
that we're envisioning we really need a
couple of things we need near real-time
access to the data so that we can create
visualizations and introduce it to the
patient care units so that they can
start understanding and learning what
when when the unit is like you know
feels like safety safety is compromised
what metrics are high and then after you
learn that you can start compiling those
metrics in a more intelligent way so
over time you can grow the value and
sophistication of these proactive safety
metrics over time and then if you want
to start looking at like what patterns
are associated with medication errors or
that sort of thing you need to kind of a
longitudinal records that you can go
back and look at and so the goal right
now is to create
initially the flow of data and then
real-time visualizations and an archive
to support research and oasis you have
purchased a software
Splunk that is designed to read machine
data and it's used in itg right now and
it's kind of a happy accident where
they're looking for more clinical use
cases for use of the software and so Tim
thank you for being here is working with
me and itg and we're actively meeting
with our sources to owners to get
permission to get the forwarders in
place to create the data stream that we
need for research so what are the
research questions that we might ask
this is the next step where I really
need to hone in and just several of them
and do a deep dive but I see the
research questions really spanning four
categories this data I believe can help
us improve situational awareness it can
help us generate questions about our
clinical practice it can and hopefully
help us develop proactive safety metrics
by identifying these latent conditions
in the workplace environment and
ultimately it through the collections of
the metrics and situational awareness
helped us achieve more data-driven
operations these questions were
partially there they're based on my
interactions with the clinicians over
the summer and some of the questions
that came through were like how can I
use this data I think it might be able
to help me help my charge nurses know
when to ask for help there's a lot of
subjectivity that goes into that and
there's a variability in terms of
people's thresholds of feeling when they
know when we really need to go ask the
house for additional resources another
question was how might it changed the
way we make patient assignments there
was a lot of it was kind of exciting to
see clinicians start to look at the
ambient data which had never seen before
and it started pumping questions like
how come do we use a lot of that supply
at this hour every day I really don't
understand that it makes me want to go
and learn this and so this is just
access
to this day they will trigger a lot of
questions about clinical practice and
then in the situational bucket it's you
know really one of the nurse managers
really wanted to help understand what
drives errors one unit they hadn't had a
fall in days and days and days and then
what happened and it's like why was it
it was it was the nurse was there's
different activity level like what how
can we start learning what's putting us
at risk for different adverse patient
events so to get to where we are with
the idea at this point in time I have
many many people to thank people at OHSU
hospital who provided access dr.
Eldridge and others who really helped
open doors to gain access to data and my
faculty advisors here at demise the itg
and many other people who were at the
technical level of contributing data and
then i neva need to think of the guys
that swamped because they I didn't know
about the need to use font for clinical
use cases and it was actually them that
provided the introduction to Omar and
Tim so with that I would like to open it
up for questions and discussions thank
you for the reminder if you just please
push the button so that everybody out on
the web can hear the question
so this is big open space lots of new
data that's always very exciting
especially something we think is
associated with something but we don't
actually know what stuff you know in
your mind what's the low-hanging fruit
hypothesis research questions that you
can ask of this because going to be a
big task to get all this together and
normalize it and all that and just be
able to be able to look at it right but
you can't really build a dissertation
off of looking at it you have to have
some hypothesis as you're testing so
what do you think is the most basic kind
of core thing that you're likely to be
able to get you know interesting results
from that isn't too too grandiose yet
yeah that's a great question thank you
I you know I went out to literature just
to look at is anybody using this data
yet and I only found two studies and one
of them looked at frequency of taking
file science and it was an exploratory
study and their premise was that
clinicians have kind of a sense of worry
that grows about a patient and one of
the ways that that sense of worry is
reflected is they take vital science
more frequently and so in this
exploratory study they looked at the not
the content but simply the frequency of
documenting vital signs in the 48 hours
before somebody had a heart attack and
what they found was that there was more
frequent biocides taken in the 48 hours
before a heart attack and if you lived
or died the patients who passed had more
vital signs taken than the patient who
live and so it was an exploratory study
I met the author at a Mia and it looks
like they're going to get funded to take
that a little bit further so that's one
example in current work but your
question of low-hanging fruit I think
that if you look at blood errors are
fairly infrequent events but that's
definitely an area of interest right now
with Pharmacia exploring the barcode med
administration data to see if perhaps we
could look at when you started to give a
med but backed out of it and if that's a
proxy measure for a potential Meador and
could you look at activity patterns
related to backing out of giving them
that
as basically a latent conditions that
are associated with near-misses
would be one an outcome that's very easy
to identify as overtime that would be
another one but I think would be
low-hanging fruit and financially
related absolutely dr. Nunez like Boozer
I'd like to add something to that or
just a thought on that thank you is the
frequency with which vitals are taken we
have a rapid response team at the
hospital that can be deployed to
patients who are deteriorating to either
say well they need to go to an ICU or to
stabilize them and it relies on somebody
saying hey we need to call the rapid
response team this could be an early
warning sign and there is a group
looking at early warning signs using
data not human interpretation of data
and if for example we find that the
frequency of vital signs is a trigger
for people who are deteriorating that
could be a flag to get the rep they are
are teaching early and because what we
found is the earlier you get the rest
response to you the less people will die
or they get to ICU faster which is the
right thing for them which sure is
another thought is that I in the recent
past doctor notice and I had a
conversation about PRN meds and looking
at the frequency of PRN meds and her
specialty is on pulmonology and what you
know a scenario that we were kind of
theorizing about is like patients who
are medicated for anxiety when it's
really a duty repulsion and then it can
get a little bit too far before you
really realize what's going on with a
patient and maybe if we look at these
increases in PRN use that those might be
associated with rapid response calls
would be another idea potentially a
low-hanging for you to look at dr.
Foreman not forgive me for putting the
fruit out of reach but one of the things
that's most exciting to me about this
work that you're doing is the potential
to combine kinds of data that haven't
been combined able before
so data about nursing and medications
administration and all that it's kind of
the same universe but data about going
to x-ray or when your meal arrived or
all the other stuff that collides with
patient care and so if we're trying to
figure why I'm Ed was later why
something happened and why the patient
wind failure because they ate all that
salt I don't know but the potential to
combine stuff from completely different
realms which I think mystify me as I go
through the hospital and wonder why
things are bumping into each other all
the time that may extend the the fruit
out of reach and yet I think there's
great potential there thank you
Thank You excellent suggestion Thank You
wonderful talk I mean you know and I'm
interested in this kind of things with
oxidants but two questions one is about
what you could just said in one one
without the trajector I was that I
offered the frequency of vitals like
he's looking at a physician being
concerned of a patient and therefore the
frequency which he tests like all she
tests Lydell for isn't that confounded
because he or she already has them
whatever they are cognitively some
features that gives the concern and
you're looking at a confounded feature
which is their concern and the frequency
by which they send the vitals so let's
just a cut the thought and which I would
like to answer or not but the other one
was in the specific level you showed was
the patient's trajectory how how would
you think is best to put patients who
have a different day zero a different
length and a different end date to say
oh look at their ends they had they saw
more meds but their ends are different
their times are different and you know
there's lots of variation I'll answer
the second question first because I
think you're going to need to really
figure out how to window you looking at
this data like is it looking at
hospitalization are you looking at
trajectory over a day over two days over
a rolling number of hours I think we're
going to have to that you know
identifying that unit of time measure
and how we we bucket that is going to be
an important thing to figure out
- the first question we're like is there
some confounders around frequency of
vital signs I think seems like that's a
very valid concern
I think perhaps what we're looking for
here are meaningful metrics that help
you shape your actions in the clinical
care environment not always causal
like a causal cause-and-effect
relationship for example like the
frequency of violent it's never going to
be a causal relationship like how many
times revivals are taken doesn't cause
your heart attack but maybe the number
of times that your vitals are taken may
be an indicator that allows you to have
visibility into the concern that's in a
clinician in mind that in a in a way
that doesn't require extraction of data
from the EHR from a you know just a
simple device if used at the bedside may
give you awareness that hey we need to
prioritize focus on this patient today
in this shift that answer your question
partially yet because I see you're
looking at a system side you're just
looking at once something happens let's
say let's end this legal team on to see
what happened but I'm more concerned
like if you're going to have a smart
system one day in the future that the
hospital that targets these patients and
identifies them ahead of time this is a
patient of concern the physician has
some features in his or her head that he
or she is using that determines that
better than the frequency at which he or
she sends the vital absolutely doctor
notice so we were just talking about
actually I think a large portion like
mine the physician doesn't order the
vitals difference and may not even be
aware that they're being checked more
frequently it's actually people at the
bedside who are saying this doesn't look
quite right and that's what's what if
you look at what's borders it would be
discordant with what's actually being
done and that's another thing that we
can look at not like there's a physician
it's probably going to be more likely
the staff nurse at that that's died
again and so the vitals will be ordered
you know every eight hours or every four
hours or maybe an ICU every few hours
but it doesn't that's not like a maximum
amount of time it's like you totally
have flexibility that they decide to do
it as frequently as you need in order to
pick up funds a change in condition kind
of ties in with clients notions in
powers of mind of the gossip book when
people know something's wrong but don't
know water
why and that thing that comes from
expertise so the expert nurse at the
bedside or could be an MA but just as
this is funny in takes vital so there's
something going on and no one recognizes
yet what it is and it is until tomorrow
so it may or may not be someone's
hypothesis and if it is someone's
hypothesis we don't even know whose it
is and they don't know why they've got
it but this might enable you to tap into
it and sorry one more thing on this
because I do work with the group that's
studying these early warning signs
people under call for help because they
don't have a numbers they're like well
the blood pressure is lower than this
and that's what it says to call and we
actually encourage people is if the
staff is concerned or worried you should
call a rapid response but people don't
feel comfortable with that and this
would be a way to get that discomfort
and hesitancy out of the system is what
they found in large studies is that 8 to
16 hours before somebody codes or goes
to a nice view there's usually vital
sign avid about trends and but it's not
until they reach some magic number that
people suddenly say AHA this is a
problem so what you're talking about is
what he said at the beginning which is
making the system support us so it's not
just relying on humans these are acumen
but the system is promoting what you
should be calling yeah ding dr. door so
I hear a conversation that there's kind
of two parts it's sort of highlights
what Aaron was talking about but there's
there's one you can use new data to do
anomaly detection which this data is
sort of set up in some ways to do like
what's something that's very unusual you
can look for patterns and find that it
or you could use the data to sort of
describe systems and then predict sort
of the next stage of the system or
something to see you know and you've
given a little bit of examples of both I
guess which of those is
or interesting to you and how might you
differentiate between them and how I may
be this is a sort of a broader beat
question you get you're going to have a
lot of positive validation especially as
you integrate the data like the meaning
behind the data is really not known is
sort of what you said and how you get at
that meaning for those two cases very
different actually in general there's
different emphases on both so you have a
sense of how you might approach that
thanks for the question the anomaly
detection it kind of forces you to put
things in two buckets either you're
normal or you're abnormal and I guess my
own personal thought is that for
something that may be a little it may be
difficult to understand what normal is
and normal may change over time and so
putting things into buckets like that
maybe not quite as helpful as
characterizing activity or
characterizing what is the phenomena
that you're studying and if you're if
you can classify it into different
levels and then look at how those things
relate to an outcome of interest I think
that's where I would probably focus my
attention rather than anomaly detection
that's a great question Thank You Nathan
I guess some of the richest data that I
had more than one source for would be
medication data because you have what I
got was the on the cell record of when
it was dispensed from the device and I
got this very late in the game so I
haven't completely really looked in at
the barcode med administration but
that's another way of like when was it
scanned and then there's a third record
which is when was it documented that it
was given in the EHR and so the way meds
are given in the hospital is like you
have a time when they're ordered like
say it's a nine and nine med typically
there's like a range of time in which
it's acceptable to give that med usually
maybe 30 minutes before and 30 minutes
after so you have an hour window and
nurses will dispense a med ahead of when
they give it a variable period of time
but they're not supposed to be carrying
around meds that aren't labeled and so
that's you know one thing you could
start looking at it's like what's the
difference between like when they were
dispensing when they were given but
maybe more to your point is like how
could you help validate is like what is
rooms between the bar code
administration time or the barcode scan
time and the time that it was documented
in the EHR those should really be pretty
close together and if you see
discrepancies it's it kind of makes you
wonder you know is a nurse adjusting the
time to make it look like she's
compliant with a 30-minute time
administration window and would the
barcode scan time actually be more
accurate than the EHR documentation time
so we're having a blast out here so what
she just said reminded me of a concept
from lean called more rough
amory rather we mostly talk about muda
which is waste but Marie is
unreasonableness it seems to me when for
example when the meds work when
everyone's supposed to get their meds at
9:00
everyone can't get their meds at night
and and somehow it might be a clue to
amore there's something wrong with our
processes or our system that's putting
people in an unreasonable situation that
they're trying to figure a workaround to
it might not be they need more training
it might mean we need to create a system
that doesn't ask someone to be in 40
places at nine o'clock for example and
Maury is this thing that's harder to get
at but most of us are familiar with the
feeling of unreasonableness when the
demands of the job are beyond what we
can do I like that and I really hope
that that this ambient data can lead and
lend transparency to that and help us to
rethink some of our really entrenched
processes like the Oh 900 Med time or
the Oh 750 or that you know it's like
think about changing those is like
thinking about moving a small mountain
but obviously if we want to look at
patient safety all of those processes
should be on the table for potential
change Andy when lean comes up by happy
so so the other part of that is the
Murrah which is the fluctuation which
causes overburden so it sounds like
there's a real opportunity to look at a
system and how it fluctuates and what
causes those fluctuations so it's easy
to if you looked at nurses time for
instance that on the some they are not
overburdened because they only have on a
12-hour shift 10 hours of work for
instance but if you have three hours of
work in a two hour window that's caused
by the system which causes the over-over
burden or unreasonableness so it'd be
really interesting a macro level from a
hospital as to how the whole system
becomes overburdened and when and what
are the things that cause that is it
everyone rounds at the same time all
those different things that we don't
think about the system standpoint but
ultimately it is all part of and I love
the analogy of wire all these things
running into one another when I'm
walking through the hall is because
we've caused them to happen so from my
perspective there's all kinds of
possibilities
I'm looking forward to talking to more
about one of those where those might
work absolutely thank you for that I
look forward to brainstorming more about
that and as we as we hone in on a
research question will be interesting to
look at like how many units and I like
the idea of kind of thinking about the
hospital's assistance you like from how
many places do we want to collect
ambient data start analyzing yes yes
but that's a really great point thank
you for that and a given example of the
and I'll just kind of add to your point
a little bit in that the workflow
surrounding the ambient data has an
effect on how you interpret it for
example in nurse call you have a bunch
of timestamps you have like when the
call was first placed when it was
acknowledged when it was escalated to
another person and then when it was
finally cancelled and then you have a
duration of like when was what was the
duration of when that call was placed by
the patient and when it was cancelled or
acknowledged and if you're in a
situation where staff working out on the
hall are looking for the call light and
they go in to the patient's bedside and
cancel it that is the true duration of
the time that the patient had to wait
for somebody to answer but on the unit
that I observed the post surgical unit
where I observed this summer the the
process was that the patient would place
the call late it would it would also
ring at the central console the unit the
unit clerk would answer and say you know
hi mr. Jones what do you need oh I'm in
pain I need some more pain medication
okay I'll let your nurse know
hang up the phone which also canceled
the call and so basically it looked like
that patient only waited you know five
or 10 seconds when in reality then the
Huq would pick up the lacera and say you
know Dana your patient in 14:13 needs
some pain meds and maybe it took me 10
minutes to get so the true time that
that patient waited was 10 minutes so
there's there's a lot of things that
we'll have to look at in how we actually
interpret and make sure that we're not
making assumptions about workflow that
can look at the you know how you should
interpret the data and your point about
like how many ambien data systems do you
look at and are you missing something
it's totally valid I guess my response
to that is we have to start somewhere
and keep growing and
and that's a really great point and
something that we need to be aware of
and and develop procedures to guard
against you know like and and to be
aware if we are observing during the
question of ambien data but it it at a
you know healthcare it's a high paced
environment where you've got to just get
your work done and at some level you're
just like getting your meds out and
you're dispensing and when you dispense
them and kind of just the the nature of
it being out of an operational system I
think is going to at some level reflect
actual activity but you know good point
I mean when I talk to nurses
it was interesting like they said you
know I asked you know about medication
dispensing practices and they're like
yes I always dispense for just one
patient and then go to the bedside and
come back and get meds
but I know a lot of other nurses who
dispense for more than one and then a
lot of nurses said that same setting so
you know that that's that the practice
that's probably going on that people
aren't you know openly ready to talk
about and that's a good point cuz we're
going to have to be thinking about how
we can actually guard against
potentially negative uses of this data
that we may or may not anticipate before
we go down this path
the question had about this care yeah
one of the challenges with the
electronic medical records we'll put it
lasted and no more texts can happen we
already know that nurses are spending
somewhere between 35 and 45 percent of
their time in the records station
concerned about excellent question
thanks about girls I think I thought a
lot about missed care the the challenge
I have is how do you know that it was
missed and what data can I look at to
identify that it was missed and the the
place I've looked to for that is like
supply use like certain you know like if
you're changing a dressing you're using
certain supplies the way that supplies
are dispensed in the unit like one of
Randy's ideas was looking at
chlorhexidine and you know central line
dressing changes for example it's an
open bin that has a scale and so
basically the data that's recorded is
your quantity on hand and so it's
reduced by one every time somebody uses
something but I don't know what patient
it's used for now in some other
hospitals where I've worked
you basically dispense every single
supply to an individual patient so I
know that addressing change was and so
you could start to maybe look at some of
those if a supply is used was it was the
care missed it was a central line
dressing kit not say it was should have
been done every 48 hours and it was 72
or longer before it was dispensed for
the same patient we could kind of start
to infer that that care did not take
place but there's other things like
patient turns every two hours to prevent
bedsores how do you really get at that
and
so I'm very interested in the topic but
I'm a little short on data sources to
help me know when care was missed the
reference for thee